hi everyone very pleased to be with you
today for this lightning talk and spy
later about 2022 so we'll see how to
build the web app in Python with Dash
if you have a knowledge in HTML in
Python very basic knowledge it's quite
helpful but you don't need any knowledge
uh Dash knowledge
so what we'll be doing today will build
a very simple web app that shows uh
among the fruits in two different cities
San Francisco Montreal
so that you can see that's in a very
simple way you are able to build a web
app and that's more an example that Rick
Case then uh I can tell you more about
different options that we can
have with Dash okay
so it all starts with VIP install so if
you're familiar with python you may know
already about this about pip
we just need two packages here Dash and
pandas
so Dash comes with uh quite a few
libraries
and I talk more now about whatever it is
you will need to use for this
so we will use in this case for
libraries first Dash
with a capital layer which is used to
initialize the app
when HTML in DCC that are useful to
build components in the layout of the
app
then product Express which is actually
visualization Library
like Seaborn microflib
and that is included already in dash so
that's quite simple and integrated and
easy to use
and finally pandas
so one you have imported the packages we
need the libraries we need
we just
um right here uh one line of codes to
initialize every app
and then before to go straight to
visualization the first thing we need to
do is to have our data in a structured
way
so we've appended the frame we have many
different options we can use the read
HTML read CSV and this kind of functions
so that we are able to get data in many
different formats
in this case to make things simpler it
just creates data from scar so from
scratch
and through free dictionaries with
fruits amounts and cities
so if we print the data frame you can
see here
different fruits different amounts and
different cities
it is pretty much like they will with
also indexes in our case that's not
something that will be very relevant
but that's one
characteristic of that frames
so once you have our data structured
into the differing we can Define uh
produce visualization so if you remember
what we want to do here is a bar chart
so we call
PX which is short for currently
experience
dot bar which is a property Express
methods to build the bar charts
and then we just have to specify
parameters
so the first one is to specify where the
data comes from
it comes another case from ndf which is
our data frame
when we need to specify what we will
want to have in x axis and y-axis so in
the x-axis will have the fruits
in y-axis the amount and we will also
use color so that we can show the
information for each different City
and we also have a parameter that allows
us to choose to have a bar charts
together for a single element of x-axis
so we Define here in bar modes group
that's great we have a bar graph already
and what we just need to do right now is
to basically build a layout of the app
that's uh here where we leave that's now
that we will use uh HTML components in
dash components
so HTML components are for example the
H1
so there is a syntax here which is just
uh HTML dots components so you want to
use
so here we will have first a large div
that will include so different
components of our app
so first you have a div and then inside
this div have a title html.h1
and then a text
html.divar text and finally
there is a dash components this is C
that stands for dash core components
so you have different kinds for uh drop
down and different things in this case
we use
um that graph and graph being the
components that allows us to embed a
graph
so here we
in our case we uh just need to specify
in figure what uh graph we'll have here
we choose fig which is the name of the
graph we
we built just before
so once we have that we're basically
done just the final step is to
um
write the command so that uh the app can
be run
Dash is based on a flask server so they
got into this uh
code here comes from flask and with this
two lines here
we basically say just run the app and
once you have that in the console we can
have we will see this message so we'll
see that app is running on this
following address
let's see here that's serving flask app
so in this case the name of my app is by
tonker Ball but here it will be the name
of your app
and as we are still testing we have
debug modes on just earlier here we have
this option this parameter debug the
goal equals true so that's when we want
to see uh errors that may that we may
have
so uh we just need to click on this link
and that's it we have our dashboard our
bar chart graph
and here since it is a very simple
example we don't have interactivity and
those kind of different features but
that's something that is possible to do
easily
for people who are interested they can
share in the chat some links about other
examples of apps maybe more advanced
apps and uh
the very last thing uh to have our app
introduction is to deploy it
sets a topic for uh onward talk but I
can also share some more uh information
about it for people who wants
may want to know about that
so I'll be happy to keep in touch with
you you can send me an email this
address the ah dot shakui
c-h-a-p-o-e-i-s gmail.com or you can
find me also on LinkedIn David
that's it thank you